alto representantes de la justicia
internacional se reunieron En una
conferencia
entre ellos merrick Garland fiscal
general de Estados Unidos Victoria
aprentis fiscal general del Reino Unido
y Karim kang fiscal de la Corte Penal
Internacional
este organismo abrirá una oficina en
kievón hoy el gobierno ucraniano ha
aprobado un memorando entre kiev y la
Corte Penal Internacional que permitirá
la apertura de la oficina del fiscal de
la cpi en Ucrania en un futuro próximo
el objetivo de esta oficina es permitir
que la Corte Penal Internacional
investigue a fondo los crímenes de
guerra cometidos en suelo ucraniano
desde el comienzo de la ofensiva rusa
como aquí en bucha
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin y
todos sus Cómplices deben ser condenados
apenas acordes con la ley injustas
por todo lo que han hecho
el jueves pasado el fiscal de la Corte
Penal Internacional
visitó el sur de Ucrania para investigar
las acusaciones de deportación de niños
a Rusia sin embargo sus poderes siguen
siendo limitados ya que no puede emitir
órdenes de detención sin un proceso de
validación por parte de los jueces de la
corte